the opening scene features a nihilistic
teenage addict Nikita who has committed
her life to Anarchy drugs and violence
one night she tags along with a local
gang of thugs and heads to rob a
pharmacy upon breaking in she puts on
her headphones and hunkers down under a
counter while the rest of the gang
search for some drugs not long after the
police arrive at the scene and the
robbery erupts into a gunfight after a
while of hellish shootout all of
Nikita's accompli are killed one of the
cops then kneels down to see her
believing that she's harmless however
Nikita who is suffering from severe drug
withdrawal symptoms blows off the
officer's head with her handgun in the
aftermath Nikita is arrested and tried
after spending a night in a police
station she is presented to the court
where she is convicted of murder and is
sentenced to life in prison later some
government officials come to visit her
and sedate her with a dose of anesthesia
rendering her unconscious by the time
she comes to she finds herself in a dull
room before she she can contemplate the
situation she is approached by A
well-dressed and hardl looking man who
introduces himself as Bob the hardest
name of them all he reveals that the
government officials have faked her
death they have made it appear that she
committed the unthinkable and removed
her from prison he attributes this as
her chance to amend for the crimes she
committed in the past he further
explains that although officially dead
and buried she is now in the custody of
a shadowy government agency known as the
center following this Bob presents her
with two choices become a secret
government assassin and serve the
country or occupy Row 8 plot 30 her fake
grave confused Nikita requests for some
time to think so he grants her an hour
after the allotted time Bob returns to
hear her decision but as soon as he
steps in Nikita knocks him down with a
chair seizes his firearm and holds him
at gunpoint she then threatens him to
lead her to an exit which the latter
complies with the officers in the lobby
are alerted by this but Bob instructs
them not to retaliate after waiting for
the right moment Bob manages to distract
the girl and free himself from her grip
he then makes her realize that it's
useless even if she gets out because the
police will not hesitate to shoot her as
she's already dead officially after a
short deliberation she finally agrees to
work for the center Nikita's training
Begins the very next day and she is
taught with computer skills martial art
moves and Firearm handling even though
she struggles to Grapple with digital
proficiency she is very good at fights
and using fire arms it is evident by the
fact that she effortlessly hits the
targets with the given firearms and also
outsmarts the martial arts instructor
with her unorthodox moves alongside her
physical training she also undergoes her
appearance transforming classes with a
makeup artist amand it is revealed that
the ladder is also rescued and trained
by the center she is currently assigned
to transform Nikita from a degenerate
drug addict to a captivating fem fatal
on their first session amand provides
the teen with a wig to help her improve
her appearance she also encourages her
to practice smiling but the latter is
not fond of any of this as time
progresses the training begins to slow
down as Nikita shows more of her
childish and erratic Behavior she spends
most of her time eating painting her
room walls and watching movies as a
result of this Bob is summoned by a
superior who expresses dissatisfaction
with Nikita's progress Bob tries to
convince his boss to Grant him some more
time pointing out that Nikita has high
potential to become a professional
assassin but doubts linger he has then
granted a two-e time frame to show the
results and if he fails the girl will be
thrown out of the center and executed
the scene then cuts to Nikita's 20th
birthday and Bob approaches her with a
small cake after a brief celebration he
says that he is disappointed in her
recent progress he also warns her of the
impending consequences if she does not
enhance her performance within the next
few days moved by this Revelation Nikita
vows to make extra effort to prove
herself from that point on onwards she
commits wholeheartedly to her training
and eventually excels in all aspects
moreover she visits amand on a regular
basis to learn how to use makeup and
improve her personality during one of
their sessions amand imparts valuable
advice let feminine pleasure guide her
she also asserts that there are two
things that have no limits femininity
and the means of taking advantage of it
all men are horny and stupid Nikita the
scene then fast forwards to Nikita's
23rd birthday and by this time the young
lady seems to have adapted
professionalism everything including her
attitude and personality appears to have
undergone a profound change on that same
evening Bob takes her out for dinner
under the pretense of celebrating her
birthday they soon arrive at an upscale
restaurant where he presents her with a
gift she excitedly opens it only to
discover a pistol that he claims to be
loaded with six titanium bullets and an
extra cartridge in an unexpected turn of
events this is revealed to be her first
Mission Bob provides a brief on the task
at hand she is to assassinate a foreign
Diplomat and his two bodyguards seated
behind her then Escape through a secret
tunnel in the men's room with the
mission outlined Bob departs from the
scene leaving her alone Nikita is
clearly nervous as the restaurant is
crowded and heavily guarded by armed men
despite this she takes a moment to calm
herself and proceed with the
assassination she grabs her gun turns
towards the VIP and shoots all three of
them before rushing to the men room the
commotion alerts the guards who swiftly
start pursuing her once she enters the
washroom she freaks out upon seeing that
the secret tunnel has been bricked up
due to her past she's familiar with
being bricked up and she doesn't have
time to react to this betrayal so she
runs towards the kitchen soon after
she's ambushed by the armed guards Who
start firing towards her she immediately
takes cover behind a table and fires
back but to her bad luck she runs out of
ammo leaving her powerless just before
the guards charge towards her she she
spots a garbage tunnel and fortunately
manages to escape through that in the
aftermath Nikita returns to the center
and vents her disappointment in Bob by
beating his ass up the latter explains
that such challenges are part of the
training process which they carry out
before graduating the agents into the
real world the following morning Nikita
is prepared for release from the center
she is briefed about her new house Bank
details for monthly payments and a fake
identity with all necessary
documentation Nikita then begins her new
life as a sleeper agent in Paris under
the name of Marie one day while shopping
at a grocery store she flirts with a
cashier Marco and invites him to her
place where they end up getting intimate
as time passes by the two develop a
romantic relationship and eventually get
engaged although he knows nothing of her
real work Marco is curious about her
past and why she has no family or other
friends or why she wanted a cashier
however she manages to sidestep the
subject every time sometimes laughing ly
and other times lovingly half a year
later Nikita is seen enjoying breakfast
in bed when she receives a call
assigning her with her first mission as
a result she gets ready and heads to the
mentioned location a hotel there she
meets fellow gang members who seem to be
ready for their mission they instruct
her to disguise herself as a waitress
and deliver a breakfast set to their
Target's room it's obviously not a
regular breakfast as the cups and bowls
are fitted with listening devices Nikita
easily completes her Mission and returns
home home later that day she receives a
call from Bob who congratulates her on
her first mission as they Converse she
invites him to dinner and introduces him
to Marco as Uncle Bob Marco is clearly
happy to meet with the first member from
her family while having dinner he asks
Bob about Marie when she was young in
response Bob makes up an imaginary story
and narrates it confidently he even
throws in a bad dick joke or two after a
while of conversing he gives them
tickets for a trip to Venice purportedly
as an engagement gift in the next scene
Nikita and Marco arrive in Venice both
visibly joyful as soon as they check
into a hotel they prepare to make love
but they are interrupted by a phone call
she picks it up believing that it's room
service but it turns out to be
instructions for her next mission here
it's revealed that this isn't a vacation
but a part of her Mission Nikita is
informed about a secret compartment in
the bathroom containing a headset as a
result she goes to the bathroom
pretending to take a bath she quickly
retrieves the headset from which she
receives further instruction about the
weapon while assembling the rifle she is
told that her Target will appear on the
roof of the building right in front of
her bathroom window she quickly takes
position and waits for the Target to
appear amidst this Marco tries to talk
to her through the door wondering if she
really loves him but she can't respond
just yet however this does distract her
as she feels that she's betraying him
when she doesn't reply for a while Marco
senses something is a Miss as soon as
the target shows up Nikita shoots her
and barely manages to hide the weapon
before her fiance walks in although the
situation is managed Nikita is
distraught on the inside she feels
guilty about taking aim at the hearts of
other men the next day she meets Bob at
a restaurant where he assigns her for
another mission to assassinate an
ambassador he asserts that the
Ambassador is returning home in 5 months
so she has to get him before he leaves
he allows her to do anything necessary
but he wants the job to be clean and
smooth from the following day onwards
Nikita starts re searching her Target
meticulously Gathering all the
information she needs she surveils the
ambassador to uncover his daily routines
and collaborates with fellow operatives
to keep a close watch on him after a few
months of Investigation she learns that
they firstly need to retrieve some vital
documents from an embassy's Locker as a
result she decides to retrieve the
ambassador's personal key for this she
plants an operative in a hotel room
where the Ambassador often visits to see
his mistress next she poses as his
mistress and leads him inside the room
while his guards wait outside she then
forces him to gulp down a drugged drink
rendering him unconscious as the second
part of their mission the operative
hidden inside the room starts disguising
himself as the Ambassador however their
mission faces an unexpected hurdle when
the center notifies them of a changed
code used by the Ambassador now that
they're trapped inside the center
dispatches Victor a ruthless operative
to salvage the mission and destroy all
the evidence of the foul up not long
after Victor arrives at the hotel and
swiftly kills the guards before dragging
the bodies inside the room he also kills
the Ambassador by pouring acid on him
jeez the operative begins to yell at
Victor for going against the plan so the
ladder guns him down as well it's what
he gets for Cheating in the aftermath
Nikita assumes the ambassador's guys and
together with Victor they head to the
Embassy upon arrival she heads straight
to the ambassador's office while Victor
waits for her outside she retrieves all
the crucial documents from from the safe
but before she can leave she is caught
by a dog the barking sound alerts the
surveilling guards causing the alarm to
go off despite this she manages to make
it to Victor but they are ambushed by a
bunch of guards in the gate in a quick
action Victor takes out his gun and
starts shooting at all the guards even
though he manages to neutralize the
threats he himself gets fatally injured
with the last ounce of his strength he
drives Nikita to safety before passing
away later that night Nikita who is
devastated by the events seeks solace in
Marco's Embrace at this moment he
reveals that he is aware of her secret
life he will always love her he also
persuades her to disappear because he no
longer wants to see her work affecting
her mental state this breaks her down in
tears and she expresses that he's the
first person who cares for her following
this the two make love for one last time
as she leaves early in the morning in
the next scene Bob upon discovering that
Nikita has abandoned the center visits
Marco's apartment he tries to convince
him to reveal her whereabouts pointing
out that she's in danger because she
still has the documents taken from the
embassy but to his surprise Marco hands
over the documents revealing that he
took it from Nikita in order to ensure
her safety the movie ends with the two
men agreeing that they will both Miss
Nikita subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching